is Drake like the male Kim Kardashian
and I say that in terms of Kim is
probably the greatest influencer in
history to women right literally has
changed the way like women's faces look
around the world Drake has an aesthetic
that guys are copying oh yeah what
aesthetic you don't think guys are
trying to look like Drake No I feel like
everybody clowns him and they say he
can't dress not clothing haircut haircut
beard oh maybe I just haven't noticed it
can you look at Al's face right now I
swear to God I'm not and his beard
trying to look as much as he can like
Drake you mean just having a beard yeah
beards weren't cool until nail nail
polish you trying to look now I see what
we doing you trying to be Dr everything
I did first okay okay you trying to be
Drake bro right yeah you look like you
go to Yale stop it bro you're my
understudy right now compl it's a
compliment it's an i League school only
you would be upset you look smart and
educated educated [__] you I know